remind you that we have a town hall
meeting today at 4 45 is right after the
second talk where we will discuss what
to do beyond the formerly organized
workshops so please stay uh there'll be
you know if you would like to propose
something fun playing music uh game
night or you know doing informal
seminars there are much deeper topics
that we would like to discuss maybe we
can do that outside of the scope of a
formal talk so please come after the
second presentation today
is it going to be here right now
or 116. sorry
two doors
and I think there will be food so if
that gives you some incentive to stay
around
the topic of discussion during the last
meeting
bring a little thing in our pocket
exactly there's
we ordered snacks but they asked me for
a phone number so if this is
people contact me I have no idea what to
tell them so hopefully
yes if I get a phone call I don't know
what to tell them you say yes
okay so you know we have Virginia back
on the fine run complexity track and
it's on dynamiccraft
um algorithms which is basically
um incremental view maintenance which uh
which is you know the Airtel database
research thanks thanks a lot
okay yeah so I will be talking about
Dynamic graph problems and fine-grained
lower bounds uh but before that a detour
okay so what I'm going to tell you is
something maybe we should have said
yesterday because you guys really care
about General problems so let's quickly
talk about General problems
this was Dan was talking this morning
and this is something
that is known okay so when we talked
about uh mint plus product yesterday
Nicole talked about it and about uh
transitive closure well which is the au
pair shortest path problem actually the
same thing that she said holds in
general for these closed item potency
mirrorings we're close simmering then
mentioned it uh and it is uh it's
actually in this book by aho help craft
and Omen on these Pages you can go check
it out and it generalizes these results
of Fisher Mayan foreman and Monroe
um basically they they showed the
theorem holds for the Boolean simmering
and the tropical tendering but it more
generally it holds for all item potent
clothes and earrings and it is that the
complexity of computing the Min the
product matrix product over that
simmering is exactly the same as that
for the transitive closure
so here closed closed is like the star
operation exists yeah according to the
book here yeah
okay so this is I wanted to say this
another thing I wanted to say is that in
this paper of uh Ryan and I we write
wrote this paper about A fine grain
reductions and subcubic reducibility
there is a more general form it can
prove about uh the relationship between
this negative triangle problem and all
pressure of this paths and you can read
this here you can Define like a set of
integers that are between minus M and M
for some positive integer M or Infinity
you add infinity you pick any binary
operation that has
um left multiplicative identity and a
zero basically then the following you
can consider the following problems
Computing this Min o dot product matrix
product verification which is given
three matrices a b and c and you want to
know if the main menu dot product equals
c and then you can Define and negative
triangle problem which is given
tripartite graph with any weights from
this R you can Define the problem does
there exist i j and k so that w i k o
dot wkj plus this plus because we're
over the integers over here is defined
that this is less than zero this is
exactly negative triangle if you think
about the Min plus product and if you
have that you can prove this theorem
that the complexity that all these
problems are sub cubically equivalent so
if you have a sub cubic time algorithm
for any one of them you can solve the
other three the other two so you can
prove these more General theorems this
is true it would like to focus on
specific problems but if you look at the
reductions they follow they're true more
generally okay
all right so that was my detour so if
you have any more questions we can talk
about
um so today I'm going to focus on
slightly different problems these are
Dynamic graph algorithms
what is a dynamic graph problem all
right you have a graph it could be
directed undirected weighted unweighted
whatever and you want to store some
information about it
um and you need to be able to support
updates in certain age delete an edge
update the weight of an edge stuff like
this or you could or you could delete
insert insert a Vertex with all the
edges coming out of it or delete a
Vertex whatever how the edge is next to
it
and then you also need to support
queries every query defines the problem
that you are solving for example you
could ask queries uh can a Vertex s
reach another vertex T in your graph
that's the reachability problem or
transitive closure how many connected
components are there
and this changes when you insert and
delete edges what is the diameter of the
graph this can change drastically and so
on there's many of these graph problems
each of them has a dynamic version with
various Edge updates or vertex updates
and so on
there's also partially Dynamic
algorithms okay a fully Dynamic
algorithm supports both insertions and
deletions
a partially Dynamic algorithm could be
incremental which means only insertions
or it could be decremental which means
only deletions now there is kind of an
overload of definition here because when
we in graph algorithms we mean
incremental is all the insertions but I
guess in databases it's both right
I just want to point this out
here's an example
um
I have an undirected graph I can insert
or delete edges and at any point I can
point to two vertices s and t and I want
to know are they connected are they in
the same connected component
um and now I uh you know as I insert the
edges and delete them there's a trivial
algorithm to update uh the answer one
one way is you know in certain age I
asked and then when I answer DH I
recompute the connected components
or during the query I check is there
path from smt and that would be a linear
time operation I have to look at the
whole graph around BFS DFS and so on
that would be very expensive I don't
want to recompute
unfortunately there are very fast
algorithms
for this problem the most recent one
that I could find could perform
insertions and deletions in login Times
log log N squared
for update
I guess amortized and this much time per
query n is the number of vertices here
but it doesn't matter because M you know
it's more than squared this is super
fast much better than order n
there is a lower bound under the cell
probe model of computation that you need
login queries uh to the memory in order
to answer to update the data structure
yeah
um actually this algorithm doesn't care
you can change every query could be
about a different smt smt are not fixed
here
so yeah so so we're very close to the
lower bound yeah
this is very close to what the current
database is so I wanted to ask you about
that
we're asking about the president you are
connected I don't get it as immediately
I need to wait so much you have to wait
this massage yeah this is a extra
running temperature
it's not constant
um yeah but this is an undirected graph
okay this is very important
let's look at direct address
whatever
let's let's forget about amortize right
now okay
okay so
um let's look at director graphs right
the same problem but now your graph is
directed you can certain delete edges
and you will ask an S Reach team
okay
again the trivial update time or query
time is easy right you can still
recompute after each update or each
query and the same lower bound still
applies you still need to do login time
per update
but the best
known algorithm to support these these
things uh it has a polynomial running
time okay the current base is n to the
1.41 it uses matrix multiplication uh
but it is very far from login it's
exponential in the lower bound
and so it's uh in fact the the question
that we had earlier
this uh the this the same sort of thing
holds even if s and t are fixed okay
even if we only have this query about a
single pair
the same same situation all right
okay and why okay so I call this St
reach okay maybe you have a different
name for this problem is the
reachability
why is director reachability hard
whereas undirected retribility is easy
so for direct to graph case it seems
like we we're stuck at performing
polynomial time updates whereas in in
the undirected cases super easy
about the current techniques at least
okay so this is one one example is a
motivation and we'll see some more as we
go along
so I'm going to
give you some introduction to some fine
grain lower bounds for these Dynamic
problems and then I'll give you some
constructions that are very simple so
you can see how simple it is at least
you know with our framework
okay so here's many examples this is the
St reachability problem I talked about
this thing is given a directed graph and
a single vertex tell me how many nodes
that vertex can reach the number of
nodes reachable from a single source
this is compute the strongly connected
components this is compute the size of a
maximum matching this is a the same
connectivity problem our SNT connected
but now you have vertex updates instead
of edge updates
and this one is given approximation to
the diameter of the current graph
for all of these you can do the trivial
thing and recompute after the update or
after the query this is linear time for
all of these problems except for the
diameter which in which case you have to
run all pair shorter staffs
m is the number of edges n is the number
of vertices
durations are
parallel that's a great question
I can discuss
that all right and a lower bound is
still it's the unconditional lower bound
is log in and where does this come from
the lower bound oh it's a it's a very
nice lower Bound by patrasco in the main
they have a nice paper where they they
talk about how many queries you need to
do to the uh to your memory to in order
to maintain uh your your problem yeah
and so yeah the cell pro model uh it
completely
disregards computation it's only about
memory accesses
thank you
okay so there's a huge gap between
linear and logarithmic and we want to
give an explanation
and we'll do that with fine grain
complexity and other assumptions that we
have
okay so let's start uh back from 2010 so
petrasco was very interested in this
discrepancy and he looked at the
threesome problem which I defined
yesterday given an integer let's say the
three of the numbers in the set sum to
zero and the hypothesis is again that
you need basically quadratic time to
solve this problem in the word Ram model
um and he divides some very nice
reductions from threesome to these
problems St reachability the number of
nodes reachable and connectivity under
node updates and he showed that for
these problems under the threesome
hypothesis you need some polynomial
running time somewhat polynomial update
time or some small a bigger than zero
and this is really good
it gave the first conditional polynomial
lower bounds for problems like these
under a natural hypothesis it's a very
nice set of reductions too
so then you wonder you know this is m to
the one and this is m to the a why can't
a B1 so then we try to make A1 in a set
of two papers we brought a up to one
third
so basically for all these problems
under the threesome hypothesis your
update time or your query time has to be
at least 10 to the one third but again
it maybe you can still beat linear time
now we don't know and and these did
first from threesome we didn't have any
conditional lower Bound for the
approximate diameter problem
so okay
this perhaps suggests that we need a
different hypothesis
so
which different hypothesis
well here's one okay so here's a Boolean
matrix multiplication problem we've seen
before
uh A and B are Boolean matrices compute
or of n's per entry
the fastest known algorithm is a
algebraic algorithm that runs an N to
the currently 2.372 time
from this year it used to be 2.373 now
it's too great
um unfortunately even though this is a
very nice constant in this sub cubic if
these techniques that we use here to
improve the matrix multiplication
exponent are currently extremely
impractical so they're not used in
practice at all and because of this
people keep talking about combinatorial
algorithms which basically says ignore
Virginia's techniques and you'll do
something better so do not use combine
do not use algebraic techniques because
they incur these huge overheads and this
is of course a completely
not well defined because I could take
stress on this algorithm and make it
look combinatorial you will never know
but whatever let's let's stick with this
we want the simple algorithm and the
best simple algorithm currently is n
cubed runs in N cubed divided by log n
to the fourth time by ho Chiang Yu so it
is not nice and not not into the Omega
but it's simple and beautiful and it
runs it this much time
and there's this hypothesis again with
this completely undefined notion that if
if you can get that there are no nice
sub cubic time algorithms for BMF truly
sub cubic so basically this hypothesis
says that if you want a truly sub cubic
algorithm it will have to be like one of
these something really horrible and
impractical
people have tried to give a definition
but you can always massage for example
stress themselves we're going to to make
it look like it it is combinatorial so
it's undefined but you know you look at
it and it looks nice it's
but anyway so this is hypothesis about
these algorithms the simple algorithm
comes to basically running like n cubed
over some poly login
or something like that like that okay
um
so now we showed that if you believe
this hypothesis
not believable this was by me another
Boon you can actually get a conditional
lower bound of this flavor so basically
what does this mean so the it's
undefined but it means that if you want
to beat this upper bound this trivial
upper bump of recomputation you should
be using matrix multiplication
that's what it means that's all it means
so anything that doesn't use matrix
multiplication somewhere in there will
have an update time that's roughly
linear so you might as well recompute
for approximate diameter this was not MN
we were able to get like a square root
of n
it's still not very satisfying because I
maybe I should be maybe I can use matrix
multiplication so what so
it gives a tight lower Bound for some
problems but it's only for combinatorial
algorithms
because of this because people were very
unhappy with this combinatorial notion a
new problem was defined so by hence
they said you know what we're talking
about Dynamic algorithms so why should
our lower bounds be from a static
problem let's define a dynamic problem
that is about Boolean matrix
multiplication so this is the online
Matrix Vector multiplication what is
that you're given a Boolean Matrix a you
can pre-process it after you pre-process
it you get given Boolean vectors V1 up
to V1 VN every time you see V sub I you
have to compute a times V Supply at
least return it so you pre-process your
Matrix you store something and that
should allow you to compute the inner
products of a and VI very quickly
immediately at the same VI
all right
it's basically Boolean matrix
multiplication because you have n
vectors but it's one by one column by
column you see The Matrix
now Ryan before he even saw this
definition he had been working on trying
to pre-process Boolean matrices and
Computing a times VI and he gave this
algorithm that runs an N squared over
log N squared time for all this problem
and you can do a little bit better his
apsp framework can shave make this log
squared of n into two to the squared
login you can do better than that but uh
but still is not quadratic so the omv
hypothesis is that
this problem requires quadratic time
quadratic camera past time uh to compute
these inner products in other words the
total time to do the Boolean matrix
product is n cubed this is completely
analogous to the bmm hypothesis except
we're now removed the combinatorial
notion in front and we replaced it with
a dynamic friction an incremental
version of BMF
this makes sense so this is a new
hypothesis and notably all of these
conditional lower bounds all these
reductions we had from Boolean matrix
multiplication they still work because
they were actually doing it from this
problem anyway we were looking at the
problem column by column so they still
work so now we get
uh the same conditional lower bounds
from this omv hypothesis uh and now we
no longer talk about combinatorial
algorithms
so against arbitrary algorithms if you
believe this hypothesis and we still
have this issue that we don't know it
doesn't correspond to a very high
conditional lower Bound for diameter
all right so now
what about diameter
from the foreign
hypothesis imply the dynamic version uh
well if you can solve the OMD problem as
a cubic time yes you can solve the pmn
but maybe use algebraic techniques so
then
so it doesn't
so if you're around combinatorial for
onp yes it will but then if somebody
somehow managed to use
matrix multiplication I don't know how
then it wouldn't
okay
so now we want to discuss the diameter
and as uh Nicole presented a reduction
from orthogonal Vector so diameter so
it's natural that we consider
a reduction in the dynamic case okay
maybe in the dynamic case we would be
able to show a lower bound with this I
just want to point out this order MN is
forever after every update your
recomputing all pair shortest pass this
is insane okay this is it from dense
graphs this is cubic time after each
update
okay linear time I understand but
MN so I really for a while didn't think
this is the right answer I thought you
know we should be able to do something
better here but as you will see if you
did then you would resolve strong xch
so that would be very interesting
okay so just a recap of what Seth and
Olivia are you you've already seen it
several times but again it's the strong
exponential time hypothesis says that uh
there's no 2 to the one minus Epsilon n
time algorithm that solves K set for
okay
and OV you have to uh today I'll Define
them as
two sets of vectors both of size n
yesterday you saw it with one set but
this is an equivalent formulation okay
now you have two sets of n vectors
binary over small Dimension D is n to
the little one decide if there's a
vector in a and a vector of B whose
inner product is zero
this since this is equivalent to the
previous version uh you have the same
hypothesis OV requires quadratic time
and Rise reduction that I presented
still uh in this says the stronger
theater implies this hypothesis now I'm
showing this to you because now I'm
going to generalize it
okay
we had two sets for two for orthogonal
vectors there is a problem called K
orthogonal vectors in which case and
where you have case sets of n vectors
each again binary over a small uh
small length and you want to know if
there's a vector in every from each set
so that they're generalized in a product
is zero the generalized inner product is
defined as the sum overall coordinates
of over the product of the vectors in
that coordinates and being zero because
the vectors are binary means that for
every coordinate one of these vectors
must be zero
this is kov
you look at so the K orthogonal vectors
hypothesis says this problem requires n
to the K time
okay and if you look at Ryan's reduction
and massage in a bit you'll get that
strong th implies the kov hypothesis
now there's uh you might ask you know
is how does kov relate to the original
OV well you can reduce every any kov to
OV so oh the two two set of the uh
problem is the hardest out of this so
you can reduce all the K you can reduce
K to K minus one so it gets harder as
okay it goes down uh so this is the
problem
questions here
all right so now
if you assume strongly pH or kov for
some K that you choose then you still
get
linear conditional lower bounds for
these problems you don't get anything
for St reach or Max maximum matching at
least I don't know how because roughly
because the quantifier structure is
different
but you do get an MN conditional lower
Bound for approximate diameter
so if you believe the strongest
potential time hypothesis the best you
can do to approximate the diameter
dynamically is to recompute all pair
shortest paths after each update
which maybe you should have you believe
the stronger th is not true
okay
so this was my introduction questions
yeah I think anything if we uh wiggle
the approximation ratio yes yeah yeah
you will I will show you about
approximation four thirds the same holds
for three halves and you can get
probably get other stuff in between I
haven't actually worked it out but it'll
be kind of similar to what Nicole showed
as an approximation hardness trade-off
uh from yesterday
okay
so what I'll do now is I'll give you
three little examples of constructions
to see how simple things are once you
have the right problems to start from uh
and all of them will be from
orthogonal vectors or kov for some k
the first one will be for maintaining
the number of nodes reachable from us
from a source in a directed graph
okay Dynamic single Source searchability
given a source s and a director graph
which nodes can I switch this you can do
in linear time
right this is not the dynamic problem
this is the static one in the dynamic
one we delete and insert edges we want
to know how many nodes s can reach I
don't I don't need to know which ones I
just want to know how many
okay
the trivial solution is after each
insertion of deletion we compute it with
DFS
or uh during the query time you can do
it either way it's linear time
in 2004 showed that if your graph is
dense enough you can do a little bit
better using matrix multiplication so
you can get n to the 1.5 let's say
update and query time which you know if
your graph has at least n to the 1.5
ridges is better than recomputing from
scratch
and there's no non-trivial solution for
sparse graphs yeah what happens if you
only care about insertions
um
good question uh
I think so yes for insertion you can
yeah or I think yeah for instance
foreign
for but once you have fully Dynamic it
becomes interesting
okay so what I'm going to show you is
this theorem
if you can get
sibling a truly sublinear time queries
and updates for single Source virtual
ability then you can solve orthogonal
vectors and sub quadratic time and set
this false
so this is for the star standard
orthogonal vectors uh and we'll just do
the reduction
this is how the the reduction will go uh
we will create given us an instance of
orthogonal vectors we'll create a graph
an initial graph which your data
structure can pre-process
okay and after that we will have a stage
for every Vector in the orthogonal
vectors instance
what does this stage do
it inserts a very small number of edges
D edges which will correspond to the
number of dimensions in your vectors
thank you there's no wonder you're just
a little more
yeah so you insert
this many edges which is the dimension
without the one and after you insert
these edges you have a single query that
you have asked how many nodes can I
reach now
it'll say something
then we'll remove these inserted edges
and move on
and from all these n queries we will
somehow figure out
uh whether there is an orthogonal Vector
pair
and queries n to the one plus little one
updates
okay and if I can set this up
because the number of updates is this
much oh and the number of edges in the
graph will be n to the one plus little
of one then
enter the one percent or one to the one
minus Epsilon will be roughly n to the
one minus Epsilon time query and update
times the number of queries it will get
n to the 2 minus Epsilon time and we'll
solve set
all right so let's do it so this is the
graph after pre-processing let's go
through it so
every Vector will have a node on the
left we have coordinate nodes over here
and we have edges from right to left
from a coordinate to a vector if the
vector has a 1 in that coordinate
so every coordinate will have a one from
all the every Vector will have an edge
from every coordinate that it has a one
two
and then there's no other edges so this
is the original graph you create in your
data structure pre-process it this is
the source currently has no edges and
we'll always be asking queries about how
many nodes this node can reach
all right now we start a stage for a
vector U and orthogonal vectors instance
what do we do we'll add some edges from
the source to the coordinates
we'll add an edge from the source to a
quarter coordinate e if the current
Vector U has a one in that coordinate
so we add some measures exactly to the
coordinates for which the vector U has a
one in
all right
what happens here so s The Source can
currently reach every coordinate that it
has a 1n
and let's and we can we know how many
there are because this is the number of
edges we inserted let's call them X
can also reach every Vector that it is
not orthogonal to
so it can reach a vector here if it
shares a coordinate in which it's one
so it's not orthogonal so you can reach
everything it's not orthogonal too
and you cannot reach anything that it is
orthogonal to
so there exists some Vector here V that
is
um
orthogonal to you if and only if the
number of nodes reachable from s is less
than n
plus X
so when I ask the query how many nodes
can s reach if I get less than X Plus N
I know that there's an orthogonal pair
involving U and I can even stop and
return
otherwise
I delete that just move on to the next
year
I have n times D updates so D updates 2D
really D insertions and D deletions
roughly per uh per vector and there's n
queries and the number of edges all
together is order n times D because
there's only an edge whenever a vector
has a one and subcoordinate
so send D D was Tiny is n to the letter
of one so this ND is n to the one plus
little or one
and therefore if we can solve this
problem is sub-quadratic time in the
number of edges this will be sub
quadratic in the in N which then can
solve uh OV for in sub quadratic time as
well and therefore set will be false
okay
it's extremely simple as you can see I'm
just going to insert and delete and
whatever and it's the same problem
in these guys questions about this yeah
oh I can well I have to delete I just to
encode the next vector all right so I I
encode Vector U by by the ones over here
and then I delete the mm and insert the
next vector
if I leave these edges in here and I
insert another edge here then
uh it won't encode the next vector
so I won't be able to tell whether or
something
like so
so I need
all right
so this is a simple example now I'm
going to show you
something for a strongly connected
component
be very strange it will say that even
just maintaining whether the number of
strongly connected components in the
graph is more than two
is difficult
let's talk about strongly connected
components
in the static version
the strongly connect components in a
graph but here and here can be found in
linear time in a graph of image DFS and
so on
in the dynamic algorithms case you want
to insert and delete edges and you can
support maybe one of two queries maybe
both one type of query is are u and v in
the same strongly connected component
and the other one is how many secs do
you have
and all known algorithms that can
support query one can also support query
2.
there's no but actually there's no
reduction so I would love to see a
reduction to say that if you can support
query one then you can support query two
but I don't know how to do it in a black
box way anyway so let me talk about like
if if you have only insertions or only
deletions
um when when the algorithm is only
insertions are only deletions what we
typically do is we measure the running
time in terms of the total running time
the sum over all the updates because
when you insert you can only insert
you know up to M for some M and A delete
you start with a certain number of edges
and it cannot most delete all of them so
this makes sense
if you have only insertions
only recently uh there were some there
was some progress in this problem this
is a very annoying problem I spent some
time on this is to try to have a very
small update time and there's this nice
paper that shows that
no matter how many insertions you do the
total update time over insertions is no
more than N squared login which is great
if you insert up to N squared edges but
because on average or amortized your
running time would be login
but unfortunately this algorithm also
runs in N squared login time if you
insert n edges
so this is not good
so this is great for for many insertions
and this is the best running time right
now for uh for a small number of
insertions so if you insert M uh edges
the total running time is m to the four
thirds but this is randomized and
there's a a different algorithm for
that's deterministic for deletes only
recently was shown that you can
basically have M poly login or M to the
OnePlus little or one total update time
which means that your amortized running
time for deletions is great
but the moment you allow both insertions
and deletions it becomes pretty bad
so in other words if you do only
deletions you get basically poly login
amortized time and for only insertions
you get m to the one third which is much
better than recompeting from scratch
which would be linear attack
fully Dynamic the best known solution is
to just recompute the strongly connected
components from scratch
when you're doing sections and deletions
it will show that under strongly th any
fully Dynamic algorithm that can answer
the queries is the number of strongly
connected components more than two
will require linear time basically which
is might as well recompute from scratch
again maybe it will it should say the
strong ath is false or maybe these
problems are hard I don't know one of
the two
okay
so the the reduction will also be super
simple so just do it in one slide but
let's set up the framework again there's
a typo here this is the one is on there
I copy paste it and the type of replay
it remained it's okay so
it will be very similar to before it
will have some we'll create some initial
graph and then we'll have a stage for
every Vector in the instance in the
orthogonal vectors instance this one is
not there imagine is gone so you insert
the edges your query is the number of
strongly connected components more than
two if it is you return there is
orthogonal Vector Spirit otherwise you
delete the edges same ideas before
and the same sort of stuff holds the
number of edges becomes n times D which
is small so a sub quadratic in M becomes
sub quadratic in N for orthogonal
vectors which refute stronger th
so I will just show you the construction
now it's the same idea as before
this is the graph after pre-processing
you're given a an instance of orthogonal
vectors for every Vector you create a
Vertex here there's n vectors for every
coordinate n to the little one you have
these nodes over here you have t which
is some node over here isolated and you
have a node s where every Vector node
has a an edge directed towards s and
every coordinate node has an edge to
every Vector that has a one in that
coordinate very similar to before
okay you throw this graph into your data
structure it does some pre-processing
and now you start the stage for every
vector
we start a stage for vector v and the
updates will be in red
first we're going to add some edges from
s to the coordinates
these edges encode the vector they say
what coordinate is the vector one in you
put these edges just like in the
previous reduction and over here you add
bi-directed edges these bi-directed
edges are for the coordinate that the
vector is zero in
okay and that's all the edges that you
add you add exactly oh D or 2D or
something at most 2D edges in here
first of all there is no path from s
to see if the current Vector has a zero
and C because in order to go from from s
to this part over here you can only go
to a coordinate in which you have a one
and then you jump to some other Vector
then go back to S but then again you can
only go to a coordinate which you want
so you'll never go to a coordinate which
you're zero
and similarly because T only has
bi-directed edges two coordinates in
which the vector is zero there's no path
from s to T
t on the other hand is an a strongly
connected components with all the
coordinates that the vector has a zero
in
and S
is in a strongly connected component
with all the vectors that have a one in
the coordinates that that V does
all right U and S for some of you over
here are in the Stream strongly
connected component if V and and U share
a coordinate and which they want so
they're not orthogonal
so in other words if all the vectors
over here are not orthogonal to V then
this will be a full strongly connected
component and otherwise if some Vector
here is orthogonal to V then it will not
be in any of these two and it will be
isolated so there will be more than two
so the number of strongly connect
components is to if there's no Vector
orthogonal TV and it is more than two
otherwise
so we do this to you remove after we
learn that it's not orthogonal to
everything that we just remove its edges
and so on and we'll move on to the next
vertex and so on and we solve orthogonal
vectors
I really wanted to show this for is the
number of strongly connected components
more than one but I cannot make it a
single component from order to so
maybe that problem is easier
questions here
for connected components I mentioned it
in the beginning connected components is
unlike strongly connected components has
a very nice algorithms Dynamic algorithm
with login times logo again squares
so that's easy because you can you can
put trees in there and start a connect
electrical ones can be captured by trees
okay
yeah so
um maybe I should bring this up and
maybe people here know more than I know
but there wasn't some open program to
find that model theory if you can
maintain the strongly connected
components were actually private
enclosure if you can maintains the same
parts of the logic yeah hmm and that was
uh closed about that one six seven years
ago by Thomas fentic and some of his
students so but the things that if you
if you have it structures
will you insert a new Edge then you only
need a virtual damaging expression to
computer updated on the disclosure
logic expression they have to be um
linear well linear in the number of Yeah
we actually don't gain anything except
the satisfaction that you can
Expressions
but maybe you'll get some reduction to
orthogonal vectors somewhere that would
be interesting too so yeah that's
interesting about parallelism with our
eyes because it is
very good yeah
that's exactly right this is the class
Dynamic F4
finally merman in the mid 90s and they
got that you can maintain in a first
order way
undirected to its ability and then they
had spanning trees and insertions on
here and it was open for incentives and
divisions and that was all but first
order queries are horrible right yeah
essentially the triggers astronomers
explained to this
Matrix inversion so they managed to
express Matrix
uh
it's like computationally intensive task
Matrix and version
they can do it from binary
binary
okay that's really cool
[Music]
thank you
okay
and we'll find the final thing I want to
show you is that diameters
so diameter instead of linear time
perhaps that you have to do all pair
service fast so you have to do MN number
of registers number of vertices per
update again from stronger th
ief okay so our preview of like I just
yeah let me tell you about diameter so
we have an undirected unweighted graph
and we maintain an insertions and
deletions
and we want to know the current diameter
of the graph again the diameter is the
largest distance and I'm okay with
approximate answers
in particular like you know
four thirds approximation one plus seven
good approximations
the material thing again is you
recomputed I actually create an update
which is a man time if you use BFS from
every node
uh and we show that
three OV which I defined earlier the
three version of the terminal vectors
uh if you assume it can't be solved
faster than cubic time then you need a
method so instead of two will be
nowadays here
all right
three of you let me remind you you have
three sets ABC the dimension errors
again here because I copy pasted into
the little one Dimensions we want to
know if three vectors one from each set
are orthogonal and the hypothesis is it
needs cubic time
the setup is again we make some initial
graph for every now for every Vector in
the set C so the initial graph will
encode the vectors A and B and then for
every Vector in the set c will have a
separate stage we'll insert remove the
one here and to the little of one edges
and then we create a diameter algorithm
if the diameter is more than four
will return there is an orthogonal
triple if it is less than or equal to
four or less than or equal to three then
um you know we continue and then we
delete the D edges and we continue we
keep going
um this should be at least greater than
or equal to four here again the number
of updates similar to before is ND is is
the number of edges which is n to the
one plus little or one
um and if you could do better than m n
here that would be better than ends so N
squared per stage there's roughly n
stages and so it'll be better than n
cubed overall so that will review refute
three of you
so uh we'll go into the details in a
second
okay let's start with the initial graph
for the sets A and B we create nodes for
the vectors in a notes for the vectors
in b now for the coordinates we're
actually going to create two sets
we encode the vectors in a over here to
this coordinate so for every Vector in
every coordinate we put it on edge
whenever there's a one and the vectors
in B are encoded here for every vector
and every quarter and we put an edge
whenever it's one there's no edges in
here here we have this gadget a path of
length two
I'll tell you what it does but basically
Z this now Z has an edges to everything
and here Q has adjust to everything and
here P has edges to the middle and we
have this edge here
the entire purpose of these nodes is so
that every pair of vectors that is not
one here and one here is a distance at
most three
okay so these pairs two nodes in here a
distance two through this node two nodes
in here distance two through this node
another here and a note and here is a
distance three like this similar like
this to go to here you go this way
anyway every pair of nodes that is not
one from the left and one from the right
error distance at most three so if the
diameter is more than three it will have
to come because of a distance between
this a node here and a note here
I think
so zpq ensures that all distances are at
most three except for those between a
and b
okay
all right so now we start the stage for
every Vector in C we're going to insert
edges in here
what Edge is to insert we just in for
every coordinate we check does the does
that Vector have a one in that
coordinate we just add an edge there to
add some edges and it will basically
there will be a matching which encodes
the vector X and C it says which which
coordinates does it have a one
and we this only inserts D edges and
we're done with with this now we ask
about the diameter
if for every triple of nodes you in here
being here next in here
uh they're not orthogonal that means
there's some coordinates so that U is a
one in that coordinate V is the one in
that coordinate and
X is the one in that quarter which means
that the edge CC over here oxes exists
so if for every pair over here they're
not orthogonal there is a path of length
three
if for some pair this u and v over here
together with X they are orthogonal then
there's no edge here that will create a
path of length three
so the only part the only way to go
between them the shortest path will be
length four
so therefore
the diameter uh the diameter is is three
if there's no orthogonal triple and is
at least four otherwise so
distinguishing between three and four
will solve three of e which will solve
set and we'll be happy
and again you know it's a very sparse
graph there's ND edges and the
insertions and so on and you get now
because the lower bound is not no longer
quadratic but it is cubic
after the end because we only have n
stages one for each Vector each stage
must take quadratic time instead of
linear in n and quadratic when N squared
means m n because m is the same as n
here
so beating MN would be quadratic time
for every stage which would be cubic
time for the whole thing which will
refute 3ov which will refuse stronger th
okay
questions about these things before I
conclude
yeah I don't know a lot about this area
so this might be a dumb question but if
you knew for instance that the degree
were bounded
because all these constructions seem to
rely on a node that has roughly n edges
coming out of it do you think that some
problems become solvable in that setting
or
um
I think you can create you can create
instructions
you'd have some animal gadgets
and also three versus four can become 3D
versus 4D for anything that you pick you
can have additive error admins and there
as well there's all these complicated
construction and we even have a
construction where instead of three
versus four is two versus three
D versus 3D all that stuff okay it's
about a degree one point save us here
reduction
there's some Productions like this yeah
so for example there's a reduction
produce Dynamic maintenance of like
maximum matching and in way diagrams to
Max and matching and unweighted graphs
dynamically there's other Dynamic
reductions as well yeah there's Notions
like this yeah
any attempts to create such reductions
automatically so in any office increased
a certain attempts and successes of
becoming automatically catches
it's a good good question yeah we should
we need to Define the classes of Damages
and then search for these gadgets like
combiners
all right as a recap different
conjectures or hypothesis seem to be
better for explaining different theories
usually that's because of different
quantifier structure this is probably
where logic will come in for you guys uh
some of these problems like orthogonal
vectors there exist exist and then for
all others are you know
for all for all exists which is
basically the same thing but or exists
for our exists and so on depending on
your problem you can kind of gauge what
problem you should pick to have a
reduction from if a reduction exists
um for these problems all these problems
that I mentioned here you get different
conditional lower bounds assuming what
uh different problems a threesome gives
the weakest ones but it seems like a
different conjecture from the other two
uh bmm and omv and Seth imply the same
conditional lower bonds for some
problems but not for all uh and OV
implies things for diameter and so on if
you add all pictures paths and assume
that it requires cubic time and the
number of vertices then you can get more
conditional load balance for example for
maintaining the shortest path between s
and t which are fixed vertices under
Edge weight updates for example or a
weighted max weight matching and so on
where and then you have to make N
squared time per updater query and so on
there's all these reductions you can
create many of them are pretty simple
you might have some extra gadgets that
are annoying but it's not too bad so far
yeah so that's all I have for today if
you have any questions you know go ahead
and ask
[Applause]
other examples of set Productions that
get distinguish between amortized
um yes
yes so in particular so the question is
can are there reductions that
distinguish between amortized and worst
case a lower update times so yeah in
particular for partially Dynamic
algorithms often when you only do
insertions only do deletions often
amortized you can get really good
algorithms but the same conditional
lower bounds hold for the in the worst
case partially Dynamic case as in the
fully Dynamic case roughly because when
you do insertions and deletions if you
have some these these sort of reductions
you insert some stuff you ask a query
then you delete some stuff you can you
can simulate that with a partially
Dynamic algorithm by you know when you
insert and then you roll back the data
structure to the point before you insert
it and then it becomes only an insertion
only data structure and this only works
for worst case sometimes but it doesn't
work
foreign
the shortest paths were two ways
oh
it'd be hard if the weights are in
binary and
um I kind of remember I was looking it
up for the for the case of approximation
with respect to water both of them the
way it functions
so it's that uh
I don't remember offhand but there was
some paper about something yeah I may be
remembering yeah you mean a lower bound
you think yeah there's some conditional
okay so in database
one by one
of a smooth curve
everything then basically becomes an
offline problem yes
uh I I guess yeah but
so often bash updates in the up
um in the algorithms and give you better
amortized than sometimes they can
diabetize but so for some of these
problems there are algorithms that do a
little better when you allow batch
updates and so not they won't get
exactly the same condition although
accounts but I haven't tried too hard so
excuse the reductions you actually know
all the insertions I know exactly
everything I know everything
you know everything
except for an omv which you supposedly
don't know it
so did I understand correctly that these
reductions also apply if you consider
only insertions
for worst case up after a time so if you
you know that in the worst case one of
some of these updates will be very bad
they don't apply for amortized so and
there exists better algorithms for
example for reachability in the
amortized case because they can in fact
you can do the total linear time
foreign
so for example there's a lot of cases
where you need to solve a structured
version of the problem
like if you want to do Min plus product
but you know something about the
matrices it may be the matrices have
bounded differences so they're close by
entries are close and the matrices then
it wasn't known whether you can get
better than cubic time algorithms for
men plus product and we try to get a
reduction and we failed and therefore we
got an algorithm because we knew that
there was a reduction from Boolean
matrix multiplication so combinatorial
lower bound but we couldn't get a better
one and therefore we knew that in order
to beat cubic time we needed to use
matrix multiplication and we did and we
actually got a better algorithm so this
happens a lot you try to encode
something it doesn't work you see why it
doesn't work and then you try to get an
algorithm to exploit that
uh and some conjectures were refuted uh
there were there was some conjecture
about so we actually had enough paper
about uh
equations
and listing triangles we had some we had
some conjecture about the equations over
our finite fields and so on something
that you can't solve a system faster
than the field size to the end time
where n is the number of variables and
then that turned out to be false but
then uh people changed that hypothesis
to threesome and the same sort of
construction worked and now the
conditional lower bounds to holds even
though the original hypothesis were used
you mentioned
of the Boolean matrix multiplication
hypothesis I mean there are quite a few
uh database Theory papers that use a
different version the name of this thing
that Boolean matrix multiplication
cannot be done in quadratic time
is this a no I think the all these
papers on uh
enumeration of of
conjunctive care physically conjunctive
years or three connects with uh linear
pre-processing and and constant time
enumeration oh I think they often use
this one in the number of entries or and
and and
then okay so it's saying that uh there's
no linear time algorithm for the problem
right when the matrices are dense so you
can use that and get in the same stuff
codes like the same kind of reduction
still Falls and you'll get some
conditional wall Bound for you
paper says that you cannot complete a
matrix a Boolean matrix multiplication
and time uh N squared yeah sorry then I
I didn't manage to convey the
the message that I want to do exactly I
think that's the something many Kindle
papers I think they they use the
this kind of hypothesis yeah and we use
stuff like that too
because it's it's yet another
beer okay so there's versions of this
thing you can have whereas this cannot
be done uh in less than entity on my
phone and we're on my desk or matrix
multiplication and from I guess two okay
um you can we have this you can say
triangle detection can it cannot be
solved in linear time which is almost
the same as Boolean matrix
multiplication okay we solve an x square
term so uh yeah you can use these and
the same reductions will it will work
and then you get a different lower bound
from that different running temperature
which is a strong assumption to say not
not feasible
but I mean it's a better assumption than
assuming it requires whatever
no no no idea you're assuming less we
assume more uh sorry I'm not visible yes
[Applause]
foreign